let's play another game i think i'll
stick with three two
it's nice and chill and um
yeah not worrying about dirty flagging
that last game was like a
guest dirty pre-move type trick
rancho wangdu from vietnam nice
um i've never played this opponent
before
let's go for a stafford i said earlier
i'm gonna try and be
different with opening the stream but
i don't just want one stafford
oh d4 okay we're not getting a stafford
we're getting some weird scotch
type opening
i vaguely remember studying this
actually
this is a position you usually don't
reach
because the knight's usually committed
to c6
but i have no memory of what i studied
like d5 looks interesting but then e5 i
probably should just castle
i'm castling rookie eventually this is
probably the goal
i'm not scared of e5 here because rookie
8 will pin the pawn
the pawn will be a weakness
thank you ty hipke
appreciate the sub
baby baby oh baby yeah baby
play this move
where's yasser yasser
where's the
there used to be a drop down where you
can choose the quote from yasser
but okay no time for that to focus
d5 actually kind of looks attractive
right now
i always have to be alert of
tactics like the bishop's not defended
wait what is this take a pawn
oh that's tricky or is it
okay maybe it wasn't tricky
i'm just confused because it's kind of a
new sort of opening position
my bishop b6
just a more stable square for the bishop
i want to play knight c6
we trade it's okay
a5 i would then win a piece
thank you i damma
with the bits
okay so i'm up upon have slightly
damaged structure
bishops are staring each other down
i mean i'd like to take and damage white
structure
the thing is um the pawns kind of look
potentially weak but they're hard to
attack
okay here i'm gonna have to take
i can just bishop here
there's rook d2
[Music]
might be too soon though
yeah just completing development
might want to play rook b8
whoa it's joe brune thanks joe bruin
that's the third raid of this stream but
the first raid
from a non-scrabble streamer i
appreciate that
people should check out joe brune link
is in the chat
if you're just joining i'm trying to not
lose back upon
yeah this pawn is actually kind of weak
but so
so is white's second rank
so this pawns undefended now the knights
tie down to the bishop
so i can't even take the pawn right away
um okay now i can play rook d8
i mean there's also play rook
b8 first
ah question question
i don't know play rook
rook b8 hit the pawn probably rook d is
coming next
now the knight's still tied down to the
bishop so it's a rook
i wanted to play knight g4
now what to do my time
maybe just king f8
bring the king closer
that's a nice position
yeah i'm realizing maybe i should have
played some bishop g4 move
that's no longer possible
some weird idea to maneuver
but let's hide down to the pawn some c5
[Music]
idea
also some bishops he had idea the
bishop's not doing anything here
much rather go after a pawn
um
what to play
actually don't know what my plan is
hmm
that's kind of scary i have no idea what
my plan is maybe
this and this
oh i felt i fell below 10 seconds
congratulations for people predicting
correctly in chat
it was bound to happen
[Music]
so yeah white wants to do some crazy
thing but
oh that's a move to play this
kind of losing back a pawn
[Music]
that's not so comfortable
and bishop moves here i have rook h2
rook here i have some bishop b5
i'm pretty sure that was a blunder i
mean there's this move
it gets confusing and this is looming
now
oh this should be good for me
because all the pawns are weak but my
pawns are weak too
i don't know what's going on
i know i'm threatening to take with
chuck king's a bit stuck
it's a slow move but
ah this might be a draw
actually i don't know i'm gonna play
with this for a win
oh i should not have done that no draws
i kind of messed up
no draws i'm trying to live up to that
rookview i take and then we get some
endgame
my opponent doesn't want to draw either
okay here we might have to force a draw
oops
there we go
that's so weird what is this position
okay well i'm playing for a win now go
away windows updater
that was a bad still try and fight
i'll play this and then king h4
eventually
i have to be really careful here
here we go okay i'm winning now let's go
i don't know how i'm winning this
i gave a white spreading made in one so
nifty
but every move every legal move stops
made in one pretty much
so i gave a lecture on this um
for st louis test club a while ago
it's one of these end games you must
know
it's kind of a typical position you
might get into um thinking it should be
an easy win for whites
brookin 2 versus just one rook but i've
seen a lot of people mess this up
actually the three times i've gotten to
this position two of them were draws
and both both draws i had the the worst
side i had the black side
and both my opponents actually walked
into some sail matrix
and the plan is to push
to basically keep marching up there's a
cool winning idea
this move want to play this
so the winning idea involves pushing the
pawn
uh forcing the rook back and then this
move
there's a few ways to win but yeah and
then this move
and this is one of my more favorite
lines to show because i think it's uh
it's pretty aesthetic in the way white
wins the move that i would choose here
is play rook athletes
sacking the rook but getting into
a completely winning end game
despite not having a rook
and then this move
i just realized i would have had to
there's a line where i have to under
promote tonight or bishop
i would have had to do that under
promotion keyboard trick
okay that was nice nice little end game
scenario i have to find the video where
i uh
i show this endgame strategy and
it's also very important to kind of have
a general
knowledge of like common end games
because
usually by the time you reach the end
game you're low on time
and you want to make sure that you have
kind of foundational knowledge to
fall back on so you're not having to
rely on figuring things out but you
already kind of know
what to do in the position like a
machine yes
um this is really about just like
gradually working your way up getting
the pawns to the
in this case the third rank and putting
the rook here and going for the check
okay so
uh that wasn't a very eventful game
uh let me go i'll add this to the study
whoa whoa it's wonderful let's go
yeah these games have been very eventful
so far
wait do i have the let's open another
tab
ah okay let's just go here
and there's a lot of things to address
in this game
so i'll share the opening or the um not
the opening end game first
because it's a cool idea it's not too
often
where the winning strategy in a rook
ending is to sack your rook
but in this case it works
oh ad [ __ ] yeah add foss loves under
promotions
so probably the trickier move to play
both moves are losing but maybe the
trickier move is this
and black only has two winning moves
here
it's one of these rare cases
where promoting to queen or rook
are both stalemates so you have to
promote tonight
or bishop either one is fine
you promote to bishop you you can then
um yeah
as long as you're controlling the
queening square
this could lead to mates
so yeah this is my fourth game so i've
won all four games i've played this
stream
and some of these games i've probably
don't deserve to win
um yeah the tricky thing with sometimes
with this end game
it's so easy to mess up like a lot of
players what they'll do
is they'll push this pawn too early
and then it turns into a draw after this
move
you have to be very careful especially
with like
h and g pawn that you're not stalemating
the opponent's king
because this is basically just an
instant draw
if takes or takes it stalemates
but uh yeah this is nice
and just to show there's a very
efficient way to mate here
i'll give this to chat probably shown
this at some point before
it's a useful position to like know the
the right or most precise move
this is black to move made in two
a lot of people already know it good job
chat
i know ben feingold has shown this
before in some lecture
um but yeah rather than moving your king
after which white would keep running
away you move your queen to force the
king back towards your own king
and then i think ben feingold preaches
that you sh you shouldn't play this move
because this is kind of a long distance
shorter distance is to play queen a f
or queen because you consume less energy
shorter distance
anyway um
yeah this is why end games are important
if we go back i'm sure this was just a
draw like the whole time
even when i'm up a pawn and we traded
i got this pawn it should still be a
draw
actually this so this sort of game it's
probably
easier to just reflect on
[Music]
um to see if there are any moments
missed with the computer analysis
and the great thing about sleeches is
even if you're in a study you can still
request computer analysis
with this little toggle
so it'll run the graph
yeah we played an opening i don't get
too often because
uh most people either take the pawn and
we go into a staffer
or they play this move but d4
oh black's already better
oh maybe this is yeah it's pleasant for
black this is what i played
i played all the sockfish moves
white just lost a pawn
yeah it's very natural like just you you
castle and get the e file before white
completes development
okay it's useful to know that like this
line isn't so great for white
that's still probably playable
but yeah i definitely made some error
later
but white resisted pretty well
yeah this is really tricky because both
kings were kind of in danger
white was ready to promote
king g8 apparently is a way to play for
a win
oh wait what was winning
was this
so some of these evaluations are based
on very low depth
but apparently this is winning
so key move it looks like rook teach oh
rook d2
wow if takes i
uh white queens with mate
and then white's also preventing
second-ranked shenanigans and my king's
still in danger
wow what a move that's hard to find with
low time
anyway okay
yeah kind of a topsy-turvy game
so it was drawn up until
rookie four was a blunder oh rook b6
wait or king f2
wait i don't understand why king f2 is
still drawing
i use the same idea
okay why is rook a4 losing because this
and i was able to win the pawn
so why is king f2 drawing i go for the
same idea
oh it's not check ah
so i play king h4 i'm threatening to
check and win the pawn
so white's key resources rook here
which could be played immediately and i
can't
actually win the pawn without losing
this pawn what if i
if i play this then king h3
and if i take there's this tactic and
this is drawn
yeah end games are tricky and sometimes
end games get tactical even with so
few pieces on the board
okay i sipped tea uh for sparkyzzzz
almost out of tea